But I think one of the reasons why these
people have this deep seated anger and
resentment is there is a bunch of people
out there that have these lives that are
deeply unsatisfying because I think
somehow or another through momentum and
just through just things falling into
place the way they are and people trying
to fit their lives around the way these
pieces have fallen into place,
there are so many people that are
working all day long doing something
that is deeply unsatisfying and almost
painful to them.
[inaudible] soul killing,
soul killing.
You're stuck in traffic all day and then
they're stuck in a cubicle after that
they,
they relish the time to take a shit in
the bathroom and look at their phone.
I mean,
they literally do though.
That's a highlight of someone's day.
They get in traffic on the way home.
They get home after that they're
watching television and they're fucked.
They have deep debt.
This is not like there's this soul
killing thing is not giving them any
free.
That's huge.
And you know what?
You just sit there and go and you look
at what people make and you sit there
and go,
you can make quite a lot of money by
average Joe Standards and still not be
in good shape.
So I know people turn around and make
good living,
really good living and turn around go,
I'm just holding my head above water.
And so you go,
okay,
if you're holding your head just barely,
what's a person making a third or a
quarter of what you're making doing?
I mean,
this is really,
when you talk about revolutions
happening in [inaudible] and things
going down in weird,
unpredictable,
negative ways.
You and we've talked about this before,
you let enough of your society fall into
the loser class for lack of a better
word,
winners and losers in society.
If you,
every society can suck up a certain
amount of people not able to to make it,
but if that number gets large enough,
revolutions happen.
I think so too,
but I think the revolution doesn't
necessarily have to be violent.
I think the revolution can be a
revolution of action and ideas and I
think that there's a ton of people out
there that are probably listening to
this that would like to be able to do
something else.
Whether it's make furniture,
well,
they don't want a revolution.
They want to do something that's not
solved.
If you make furniture,
you make furniture for a living and you,
you feel a great satisfaction out of
that and you sell that furniture.
Look man for making furniture feels
good.
If you can do that,
you could,
you could cut those corners perfectly
and sand everything down nice and stain
it and then it's done and you get
dissatisfied and you sell it to someone
and that pays your bills.
That is infinitely more satisfying than
being stuck in some fucking cubicle
working for someone that you don't want
to work for.
Having to have these stupid fucking
office meetings,
talking to people in human resources,
sitting down with your supervisor where
they evaluate your job performance and
you know you're not really,
you know,
you,
you really need to be enthusiastic about
this company,
this company is your future.
This kind of art do you like fuck,
kill me now.
You know,
there's a lot of people out there that
would way rather do something else.
And I hope they understand that they
can.
And that's what's funny about that cause
we were in yet because we've been
talking about us and podcasting a new
medium liver,
but,
but really,
and I tell,
I give,
I rarely like to give advice because you
know,
you don't want to,
you want to be responsible for people
acting on it and having it not turn out
well.
But what I tell people is two things.
Right now,
the United States of America,
the way it's built is built to help
industry and corporations and companies.
But that doesn't necessarily mean it has
to be Microsoft.
It can be you right now you can have
your own brand and the,
let's talk about the furniture builder.
Once upon a time.
There are huge things in your way,
including needing to get loans and all
these other things to just start a
business.
So you're behind the eight ball right
away and the pressures on,
because if it doesn't work,
you're in debt.
Whereas I mean,
we started these podcasts,
there's no brick or mortar.
I mean now you've got just the,
the,
the Rogan Tower.
It's a little bit different,
but once upon a time it's like in the
back of your bedroom and you've got a
company and it's got a show and people
are listening.
If you make your furniture and you don't
have to have a brick and mortar store,
but you can put a website up,
uh,
make it with squarespace or one of those
other things and all of a sudden you
have a business out of your house.
The freedom,
the satisfaction,
the ability to set your own hours.
And here's the best part,
the fact that if you start making a lot
of money somehow you're not going to
have your boss cut your commissions.
When I,
new sales guys who made so much money
that their bosses cut their commissions,
cause you can't make more than your
bosses.
Well listen,
when you have your own small business,
the sky's the limit.
If you make $10 million,
you make $10 million.
So I always tell people that if you can,
and it's not always something they can
do,
maybe you do it on the side when you've
got your regular job.
Starting a small business now in this
climate that we have right now is not
only possible,
it's not that much of a gamble because
if worst comes to worst,
you didn't invest $100,000 you didn't
have starting at all the time,
right?
I mean at website didn't cost you that
much.
You know the,
the investment for the tools you may
have had already.
Podcasting is a perfect example.
We make business like my buddy says,
we sell Zeros and ones.
That's what we do.
Well,
it's never been easier to have a website
either.
Or with companies like squarespace,
you can develop a website,
you could literally build amazing
website and sell your furniture and you
have a free online store with it and you
put the,
they have these drag and drop user
interfaces.
You use photos,
you drag them on their sides and in
place,
boom.
Next thing you know,
you've got a website,
so your furniture.
So whatever the fuck you make,
whether you make clothes or you're
designing backpacks or there's,
there's a lot of people out there that
have interests and they've never pursued
those interests because they're fucking
tired from doing some tired warring soul
suck.
It's hard to go to work and put your
effort into that and then come home and
then work for yourself.
It's very hard.
But I'll tell you what,
there's,
there's a part,
like you said,
there's a part of it that once you start
making stuff for yourself,
that self motivating,
right?
Like I told somebody to start a podcast
and I said,
the first time you get some feedback
email that will kick you in the rear end
to keep doing the pipe.
It becomes,
it becomes,
um,
you know,
life is a verb,
I always say,
and you have to actually act,
but by acting you change everything in
your future.
Um,
another guy said to me,
it's a great line.
He said with podcasts,
it's not always how many people are
listening.
Sometimes it's who they are,
right?
So
my grandmother's philosophy was always
that you should keep walking and
talking.
But in her era,
walking and talking Mitt going and
shaking people's hands.
And now you can network like through the
Internet and you never really shaking
people's hands.
But you may have a podcast with only a
hundred listeners,
but if one of those listeners,
just some guy somewhere else who says,
oh my God,
this guy's furniture is great,
or whatever I'm to,
I'm gonna,
maybe you can come and start giving a
pottery barn.
You know what I mean?
Things open up in ways that you can't
predict because you started doing
something and because you have
legitimate passion for what you can and
that resonates us feel experienced that.
Yeah.
If they see,
I mean,
I can't tell you how many artists that
have discovered online just through
instagram or through twitter,
like this isn't sent me to creative
revolution.
Yes.
In a,
in an amazing way.
And I hope,
and I think there's way more creative
people out there than we realize.
Oh yes,
absolutely.
And I think they would love to have some
sort of an opportunity to do something
like that.
And especially like an artist,
somebody who is an artist,
man,
there's never been a better time to be
an artist because you could showcase
your work and look if you send me
something cool and you know,
he sent it to me on twitter and I'll
probably retweet.
Do we treat things all the time?
And all that takes is someone else has
to see that and say,
wow,
that's amazing.
And then took it to do to do it just
propagates to all these different
people's instagram feeds and all these
people twitter feeds and next thing you
know you've got a business and you're up
and running and it's not going to be
easy and it's not going to be quick.
But the job you're doing now,
eight easier.
Cricket,
the soul killing one eight easier
quickie that people think like,
oh how long is it going to take?
Oh,
but you know when you start out doing a
podcast,
when we got turned downloads,
well that's how it works.
We all were there while I was there.
Once too,
when we first did it,
when we,
we,
when Brian and I were first doing this
podcast and we were doing it on like
Ustream,
we would have 200 viewers and I wasn't
doing it for money.
I was at,
I was literally doing it because my,
my wife had gotten pregnant.
We had to move from Colorado back to La
and I was bummed out and I was like,
fuck,
I thought I escaped.
I thought I got out of La,
I was living in the mountains.
I was like,
this is what I want.
I want to be in nature.
I was like,
I don't want to be back in this fucking
hell hole.
I'm like,
all right,
let's do something.
And so we started doing podcasts just
for a goof cause I was doing stand up.
That was all well and good and how it
tied into your standup so well.
But it started,
my point is it didn't start out.
I didn't start out thinking this is
going to replace my income.
This is going to be,
I just did it as a passion project and I
think if people have a regular day job,
if you could just find some one thing
that you do as a passion project and
just keep building on it,
just keep at Tepe watering it.
Keep adding fertilizer,
keep giving it attention,
keep giving it focus and you can escape.
You can escape and you can be self
serving.
You could be okay.
You're going to be okay.
I always ask people when they want to
start it like a podcast.
I'll say something like,
how many listeners would you have to
have for you to care what's,
and that's a magic number that's
different for everybody,
right?
But,
but what,
what's great about what we do that's
different from broadcasting
is that there is a giant pie of people.
Let's pretend it's a billion,
and if you're going to do a podcast on
science fiction comic books from the
1950 [inaudible] or something that has
such a narrow audience,
they'd never put it on television
because it's,
it's too narrow.
You will be able,
if you even get 0.001% of that billion
pie,
it's not only going to be a decent
number of people in terms of what you
would think is successful,
but they're going to be so enthusiastic
because this is an outlet that they
don't have.
It's like I always tell somebody,
if you're into Harry Potter,
one of the TV networks given you,
but there's multiple hair,
potter
podcasts,
listen to that.
You want to hear something crazy.
Time magazine just had some top 50
podcast thing and a buddy of mine who
was angry that he wasn't on,
sent me some stuff about it and uh,
one of the things he said,
dude,
there's a fucking podcasts on there
called the Gilmore boys.
That's guys two guys sitting around
talking about the Gilmore Girls
Television show.
There's another one called something
about Richard Simmons where there is
finding Richard [inaudible],
Richard Simmons,
where they're trying to figure out why
Richard Simmons went into hiding.
What's so great about that idea though
and again,
and you at home can learn this too.
What's so great about that idea is that
they instantly tied their podcast to
somebody who already had tons of fans,
right?
So you sit there and go,
I don't know who these guys are with
this,
but I'm a huge Richard Simmons Fan.
So I'll listen.
And that's like instant audience.
And there's another podcast called guys,
we fucked these girls cramp came up with
this podcast.
And this is one that I was using as
example because these who were the girls
from God's,
we fucked.
You see it,
find the names.
Um,
these,
uh,
comedians from New York,
they came and they actually going to be
on the podcast Monday.
Oh,
that was a clever tie in.
I didn't mean to,
but I used them as an example because,
cause we just did booked this earlier
today.
Christina Hutchinson and Corrine,
she's me Crenn Fisher.
And they came up with this clever idea
for the title and it became huge.
I mean it's always top 10.
It's like one of the top 10 comedy
podcasts.
And people say,
Oh,
well too,
it's a traded.
No,
it's not stupid.
You just,
just to do something.
That's good.
Stop saying it's saturated.
If you're good,
it'll stand out.
This idea that Liverpool juicy for you
to,
everybody's got these stupid barriers
they put in their own head.
You've got to resist those goddamn
things cause they don't do you any good.
And they certainly defined the potential
for your future in a negative way that's
not self serving and it's not even real.
You know,
you've,
you've put this artificial ceiling on
the potential for what you're doing.
If you hit a wall,
okay,
that just means you need to regroup and
rethink.
It doesn't mean that wall's there.
Especially when it comes to something
like social media or like a,
a podcast,
something where you're just,
you're putting out a piece of art,
you're putting out something that you've
created this no wall as far as like how
many people are gonna enjoy it or how
far it's going to go.
It's just,
it is what it is.
And if people don't like it,
make it better.
If they like it less fixed that,
figure out a way to do it,
you can do that.
And this,
this idea that there's no to get past
the starting block today is just
ludicrous.
It's crazy and it's just this,
this poor thinking and people that are
trapped in bad situations.
One of the problems is you feel like
this is your future.
You feel like you're fucked and you
can't get out of that.
There's no hope.
There's no light at the end of the
tunnel.
There's no rainbow,
and if you feel like that,
that alone can be incredibly defining
and limiting.
But if you can look at,
if you look at yourself objectively and
say,
okay,
I Connie am fucked here.
I'm in credit card debt.
I'm working in a shitty job.
I don't like what I'm doing,
but I have some ideas.
I need to feed those fucking ideas and
have fee.
I need to feed them and water them and I
need to set aside a certain amount of
time every day to just try to make those
things happen.
You can do that.
I have a v
I like visual images.
You use that in the hardcore history a
lot.
These young,
what's it like to find an elephant with
a spear and things like that?
I liked it,
but the image to die,
that's what the image I have though for
what you're talking about.
I've always thought it's a little like
I'm a running back in football who takes
the ball and who goes forward and
there's no hole,
right?
All you run into is the back of your
offensive linemen.
But if you keep hitting,
if a hole is going to open up,
boom,
you'll squirt through.
Now,
there's no guarantee in life.
The whole will be there.
But there is a guarantee that if you're
not continually smacking at it,
then when it opens up,
you won't be ready.
Right.
And so I don't know about you,
Joe.
You've had a charmed life,
I think,
and how well you've done,
but I mean,
some of us have failed many times.
I failed at a bunch of shit.
But I guess what I'm saying is I
remember being a TV reporter at a small
station,
uh,
and,
and I would get out of work at like
midnight and the Sh and the story that I
just spent all day on aired and it was
awful.
And I would get out and I would
literally,
this is when I still had quite a bit of
hair.
I would sit there and like you like pull
your hair out and you go,
what am I doing?
Right,
right.
This is horrible.
And I look back on those now and I
think,
you know,
what if you had just given up then,
right,
or the podcast,
I mean,
do you know how my wife did a great
thing for me?
Uh,
we,
we'd had that company that I just told
you about what we were trying to do,
the new media thing and it just fell
apart and like everybody's companies
were starting to do and I wasted a lot
of time and a lot of money in my life
doing that.
And she would have been totally
justified in saying,
that's it.
You know you're going to Indianapolis,
get a talk radio show job wherever there
are higher.
But she did and she said,
you know what,
each tried to try this next thing you
can do it and here we are.
And I think you know,
if you hadn't tried,
it's that weird thing of,
and folks I tried being a TV report on
try B,
you try all those things and either
they're not successful or they're
moderately successful or they're
successful but not enough for you.
You got life is a verb.
You have to,
you know the thing that people that
makes people the most sad in life.
And I already have a couple of friends
my own age who are there is the regrets,
right?
They don't,
they don't,
they're not sorry.
They failed.
They're sorry they didn't try.
And the funny thing is there,
some of them are only 50 and they think,
okay,
my my,
my window to try is already gone.
And which is wrong too.
But folks,
you will be so happy.
There's so many things that have
happened in my life because I,
I mean I got my first talk radio show
job.
I was,
I was
a reporter.
I covered this story.
There was some big guy showing up at the
local radio station.
As I was leaving,
I wrote a letter to the program director
just say thanks for having us to,
and I thought,
do I may have this,
do I not mail it?
Do I mainly do it and just,
you know,
I closed my eyes and a male.
He called me two days later.
So you want a job?
What if you didn't send that letter?
It's a stupid,
the little things that your life can
hinge on but if you don't do them,
you don't give fate and opportunity to
intervene.
I think here's an important thing to
failure is important.
It is important.
I think failure teaches you things that
you don't learn from success.
I think failure gives you an opportunity
for self examination and also gives you
a feeling that is very uncomfortable and
that very uncomfortable feeling helps
you grow that when you feel like shit
and you screw something up.
Like when I've had bad podcasts,
my podcast is always gotten better
afterwards.
When I have that bad stand up sets,
I've always gotten better after that
because those bad sets motivate you.
They get,
they give you a perspective like,
Hey,
here's some clear examples of where you
fucked up.
Know what not to do.
Yeah,
don't and don't look at these failures
as like proof that you suck.
Look at them as opportunities for
growth.
Look at them as opportunities to be
motivated to do better.
And Winston Churchill had a line about
reading quotes about how inspirational
reading famous quotes were and he says
they motivate you for a number of
different ways,
including the idea that you know,
you think it's just you or you think
that these people who did so well,
we're so incredibly gifted or privileged
from the get go.
And when you realize none of them,
they're more like me than I think that
becomes inspirational,
right?
You telling your audience,
this is inspirational.
You don't want to hear,
go back to school,
go to this word note,
but if you hate your job,
that is like nature telling you to try
something different and it's motivating
because the motivation is you might not
have to do that soul killing job
anymore.
Well,
if you look at someone who's doing
really well,
I'd say if you focus on like Kevin Hart
or something like that is some very
famous and successful comedian.
All you see is him now flying around on
private jets wearing a new pair of
sneakers every day driving around in
bentleys.
You just see that.
You don't see him being a young kid in
Philadelphia,
going to open mic nights,
scratching and clawing Mc Hammer selling
the the tapes out of the hatchback.
Yeah,
all that stuff,
man.
There's a path and we,
we think of people like you see an old
person walking down the street,
you go,
oh,
that person's always been an old person.
Now that was a baby.
That was a baby that became a 90 year
old man.
There's a,
there's a progression that you are not
witnessed too.
You don't see it and that,
that,
that takes place in everything.
It takes place in author as it takes
place in comedians and musicians,
there is a starting point.
And then with time and focus and as long
as you reevaluate and reassess and
constantly objectively look at what
you're doing and then pursue it with
passion and focus,
you get better at things.
And you know what,
doing all those things ends up q,
you know,
it's funny,
but your life experiences create who you
are and all those things actually make
you a more,
for me,
I know I'm speaking to the choir here,
but,
but all those things make you a more
formidable person
so that eventually that next endeavor
is,
is you're more prepared for and you're
more formidable and,
and so,
you know,
you turn around and say,
what was I like as a 23 year old intern
compared to what I'm like now?
And I'm basically a different person.